bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 votre
émission pour bien démarrer la soirée au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie tout de
suite le programme de ce 13 décembre le
froid est bientôt la neige dans les
Yvelines le département était placé en
vigilance orange neige et verglas par
Météo France environ 5 cm de neige sont
attendus sur le département à partir de
ce mercredi 14 décembre jusqu'à ce jeudi
15 décembre les autorités invitent les
evinois à être prudents et notamment sur
les routes nous y reviendrons très
largement dans cette émission il est
l'un des emblèmes du château de
Versailles le bassin d'Apollon situé
dans les jardins va être totalement
rénové l'ensemble a été retiré lors
d'une spectaculaire opération de grutage
pour être acheminé dans un atelier et
très sculpture en plomb seront
entièrement restaurés redoré au total le
projet va nécessiter 18 mois de chantier
reportage à suivre et puis comme tous
les mardis un chef des Yvelines vous
propose une recette à réaliser chez vous
aujourd'hui le chef Jean-Baptiste
Lavergne de la table du 11 situé à
Versailles vous proposera une recette à
base d'huîtres elle sera à découvrir
enfin à démission nous aurons également
avec nous sur ce plateau des invités
Alain pelos bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
allez nous présenter la diag 78 un trail
de plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres qui
sont organisés en avril dans les
Yvelines c'est bien ça c'est bien ça ça
sera le premier avril 2023 ça sera la
quatrième édition la première édition
est en lieu en 2019 ça sera la deuxième
fois qu'on proposera un 100 km avec un
départ de breuil-bois Robert pour une
arrivée à Rochefort-en-Yvelines et à 100
km à travers les Yvelines et les
sentiers donc c'est un trail qui partira
du nord du département qui ira jusqu'au
sud c'est ça alors du Nord jusqu'au Sud
une belle diagonale d'où le d'où son nom
l'index 78 avec des nouveautés cette
année puisque on passera notamment sur
les veaux de Cernay sur vers la salle
des Bordes Bullion donc des nouveaux
parcours assez sympathiques qui devrait
plaire à tous les traders nous aurons
également avec nous sur ce plateau le
conseil municipal des jeunes de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui fait tracer 25
ans le nouveau conseil est installé à ce
weekend à la roue vous êtes avec nous
sur ce plateau bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous allez nous parler de ce conseil des
jeunes alors conseil municipal des
jeunes c'est qu'est-ce que c'est bien ce
sont des des jeunes qui ont été élus
donc au sein de leur établissements les
écoles primaires les collèges ils sont
25 et c'est pas un hasard puisque aussi
ce sont les 25 ans de ce conseil
municipal des jeunes à voisins on
rappelle s'il y a que 2000 conseils
municipaux municipaux des jeunes en
France sur les 36000 communes et là
c'est 25 ans sans interruption avec et
bien des professions de foi ils se sont
fait élire ils étaient 36 25 à être élu
13 filles 12 garçons donc un équilibre
et puis là on les fait se réunir et puis
on met en accord tout tout leur projet
sur leur profession de foi alors bien
sûr ils ont ils ont énormément d'idées
donc après on collationne ce qui est
possible de faire ou pas et vous serez
accompagné de yenaël et Emma qui font
partie de ce conseil municipal des
jeunes dans quelques instants il y a
aussi les informations du jour de ce
mardi 13 décembre avec vous Régine
ralech bonsoir alors de quoi allez-vous
nous parler dans quelques instants alors
au programme on parlera notamment d'une
prime de 100 euros qui sera versée aux
personnes qui souhaitent se lancer dans
le covoiturage on parlera également
d'une centrale géothermique qui sera
mise en service à l'automne 2025 au
Chesnay rock en cours au programme
également au cours de la prochaine heure
zoom sur le nouveau projet musical du
rappeur de Montigny-le-Bretonneux cœur
thaï vient de sortir un nouvel EP nous
parlerons aussi de prends ton cabas
Simone le camion
est basée à Maurepas mais avant tout
cela coup d'oeil la météo très fraîche
de demain
je vous le disais la neige fera son
grand retour dans les Yvelines il
devrait neiger entre deux à 5 cm cette
nuit dans la matinée et les températures
seront négatives entre -1 et moins de
degrés sur tout le département ce qui va
permettre à la neige de tenir dans
l'après-midi il faudra encore garder son
bonnet ses gants le thermomètre
affichera un degré à Mantes-la-Jolie et
0° Versailles ou dans et Rambouillet la
neige continuera à tomber légèrement
avec des pluies verglaçantes près de
Rambouillet on continue à parler de cet
épisode neigeux je le rappelle 33
départements dont celui des Yvelines ont
été placées en vigilance orange à la
neige et au verglas alerté déclenchée à
partir de cette nuit il pourrait tomber
de 2 à 5 cm de neige dans la nuit à
partir de deux heures trois heures du
matin et cela pourrait tenir au sol avec
les températures négatives annoncées
jusqu'à dimanche cette nuit les pluies à
verglaçantes pourraient également se
mêler au flocons dans le sud des
Yvelines avec des risques de verglas sur
les axes routiers un nouvel épisode
neigeux devrait intervenir également
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi on
écoute comme le coup prévisionniste à
Météo France l'Ile-de-France sera
concernée donc
plutôt en deuxième partie de nuit donc
par les Yvelines puisque l'offensive
arrive par l'Ouest et donc on peut
estimer que les premiers
pour les premiers flocons sur les
premières pluies vers glaçantes aux
alentours de 2 heures 3 heures du matin
ça ne va pas se terminer comme ça
puisque jeudi en fait est une nouvelle
journée hivernale avec une nouvelle
pulsation qui se met en place mercredi
soir à nouveau par la Bretagne et qui va
suivre le même chemin c'est-à-dire que
progressivement les précipitations cours
de la nuit de mercredi à jeudi vont
s'étendre en direction du bassin
parisien et donc on peut s'attendre donc
pour la journée de jeudi à de nouvelles
neiges qui vont se concentrer
principalement entre la Bretagne et puis
le Cotentin mais avec une extension donc
prévu sur l'Île-de-France
mission météorologiques peuvent bien sûr
évoluer à très rapidement rester
informés sur le site de Météo France qui
s'affiche face à cet épisode les
collectivités responsables de
l'entretien des routes se préparent
notamment les départements des Yvelines
et des Hauts-de-Seine qui gèrent
ensemble plus de 1900 km d'axes routier
interview express avec Richard
Delepierre vice-président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines aux mobilité
et aux transports interrogés par Nicolas
dandry
sur les deux départements il y a il y a
40 personnes qui vont être d'astreinte
24 heures sur 24 à compter de cet
épisode et jusqu'à la moitié du mois de
mars et dès ce soir nos 32 saleuses
partiront préventivement traité les
points les plus importants du réseau
parce que l'épisode de neige annonçait
on parle de 1 à 5 cm le verglas par
contre on va être dans un environnement
température entre -2 et 2 degrés qui est
complètement propice à l'apparition
verglas et là c'est extrêmement
difficile d'intervenir une fois que le
verglet posé puisque le sel glisse sur
le sur la couche de glace
pour l'instant lors de priorité il est
plutôt par la classification et
l'importance de nos axes on a on a trois
catégories et on a 340 km du réseau
inter départemental qui est dit deux
catégories une c'est à dire les voix les
plus capacitaires les deux fois de voix
enfin tout les tous les axes qui
accueillent le plus de trafic se sont
évidemment ces axes là qui sont traités
en priorité
ça fait très longtemps qu'il y a pas eu
un épisode avec avec du verglas donc là
on est dans un environnement dans une
configuration météo avec un sol très
froid avec peu de neige annoncé mais
peut-être de la pluie donc la pluie sur
un sol très froid vous le savez ça fait
du verglas et comme les panneaux cette
température au dessus de 0 avant ce
weekend on est dans une confédération à
risque sur la partie verglass ça fait
très longtemps pour le coup que on n'a
pas connu ça
vous l'avez entendu dans l'interview
line 118 sera fermée à partir de ce soir
22h comment s'organise du côté de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour répondre
à cette question François alliette
conseiller communautaire à 50 ans en
Yvelines déléguer la voirie est avec
nous par visio bonsoir
bonsoir alors est-ce que tout est prêt
pour cet épisode neigeux qui sera prévu
ce soir dans les Yvelines
effectivement c'est un épisode important
comme ce qui vient d'être dit qui arrive
cette nuit alors sachez que 50 ans est
équipé pour gérer plusieurs dizaines de
sorties comme ça tous les ans même si
dans les fêtes on en gère que 4 à 5 du
fait de des conditions météo alors on a
concrètement on a quoi 51 gère jusqu'à
320 km de voirie sur l'ensemble de ces
12 communes et va pouvoir envoyer 12
saleuses qui en parallèle vont traiter
les 12 communes et les principales voies
est-ce qu'on appelle les victoires
communautaire qui sont principalement
les voix sur lequel route des bus qui
vont être traités en priorité pas bien
sûr en partenariat avec des communes qui
gèrent les principales voies communales
donc normalement tout sera bien traité
les communes et Saint-Quentin on prévu
une sortie cette nuit à partir de 4
heures du matin donc pour que demain au
réveil tous les gens puissent circuler à
peu près normalement vous avez
l'habitude de gérer ce genre de
situation alors si on a tous les ans
l'habitude de le faire je vous dis on
est en fait préparer avec un partenaire
pour gérer plusieurs dizaines
d'interventions par an dans les faits en
engager 4 ou 5 l'année dernière en
Algérie que deux du fait des conditions
météo et rassurez-vous nos équipes sont
affûtées et prêtes à intervenir combien
de personnes au total sont mobilisées
vous avez parlé de d'équipe combien de
personnes le total sont mobilisés sur
sur l'événement j'ai pas le nombre
précis j'ai le nombre d'équipements par
exemple on a 12 saleuses qui eux sont
capables d'intervenir et qui ont traité
les 300 et km mais le nom précis des
équipes je ne les ai pas non
et au total du coup il y aura les routes
importantes mais aussi les petits axes
qui seront concernés
oui lorsque je vous disais Saint-Quentin
gère ce qu'on appelle les voiries
d'intérêt communautaires si elle nous
fasse les bus donc c'est les trois
séries kilomètres auquel je vous avions
en complément on travaille avec les
communes qui sont elles-mêmes mobilisées
sur l'ensemble de leurs principales axes
routiers donc c'est vraiment une
intervention en partenariat avec le
département avec les communes et bien
sûr avec les avec les tailles la dérive
pour les pour les rôles importantes au
niveau régional vous avez parlé vous
avez parlé de cette nuit mais est-ce
qu'il y aura aussi des opérations
régulières pendant les deux prochains
jours
oui alors il y a une opération forcément
en journée demain parce qu'on prévoit
nouveau l'épisode de neigeux et
probablement une autre sortie la nuit
prochaine là on a vraiment deux jours
très délicat à gérer donc ils vont être
mercredi et jeudi et qu'est-ce que vous
conseille aux habitants de 50 ans
Yvelines
qu'est-ce que je leur conseille ceux qui
peuvent de télétravailler c'est un peu
un peu facile mais néanmoins c'est un
vrai conseil sinon c'est d'emprunter les
principaux axes justement ceux qui
seront principalement déneigés donc les
axes les plus importants éviter les
petites routes éviter les raccourcis si
je peux dire par les petites routes dans
cette norme c'est pas un peu délicate et
comment être informé sur la situation à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce qu'il y
a des solutions
alors il y a des solutions on peut
s'inscrire sur le site de 55 pour avoir
les alertes par SMS notamment qui vous
alerteront de toutes les alertes niveau
3 niveau de la préfecture et donc des
canettes importants est prévu en terme
de neige de verglas donc vous allez sur
le site de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
vous inscrivez les alertes sont
gratuites immédiates j'ai fait le test
tout à l'heure ça marche bien ça marche
très bien merci beaucoup et tout sera
prêt du coup on vous le rassurer pour
cette nuit je dirais pas que tous les il
restera forcément des petits axes privés
qui sont pas traités les grands axes
seront traités pas de souci nos équipes
sont travailleront des 4 heures du matin
pour cela donc on l'a compris pour être
alerté des opérations de déneigement
dans l'agglomération vous pouvez vous
inscrire à un service d'alerte par SMS
rendez-vous sur le lien qui s'affiche
Merci à VOUS François Liette conseiller
communautaire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de son côté
VINCI Autoroutes gestionnaire de
l'autoroute A10 a annoncé le
déclenchement de son plan neige il
concerne notamment le pH de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines plus important
d'Europe avec 80000 véhicules au
quotidien près de 70 les gens sont
mobilisés dans le département des
Yvelines et se tiennent prêts à
intervenir avec le renfort des
entreprises Colas et Eiffage le
dispositif est complété de 54 caméras de
surveillance activées entre
Saint-Arnoult et Paris par ailleurs face
aux conditions météo la préfecture des
Yvelines vient de déclencher son plan
grand froid il permet de disposer de
place d'hébergement supplémentaires pour
des plus vulnérables et de renforcer les
dispositifs de maraude sur le territoire
chaque soir ce sont près de 8000 places
d'hébergement qui sont occupées dans les
Yvelines auxquelles s'ajoutent 129
places supplémentaires ouvertes pour la
période hivernale on va
on va poursuivre cette émission avec
vous Régine ralech avec les autres
informations du jour parce qu'il n'y a
pas que la neige dans l'actualité alors
on commence par le chiffre du jour et le
chiffre du jour c'est 100 le 1er janvier
2023 les personnes qui souhaitent se
lancer dans le covoiturage recevront une
prime de 100 euros les ministères de la
transition écologique et des transports
l'ont annoncé ce matin la prime sera
versée par les plateformes de
covoiturage de manière progrès
progressive 25 euros au premier
covoiturage et le reste aux dixième
trajet effectué dans un délai de trois
mois à compter du premier covoiturage le
plus grand projet de géothermie en
Europe ce sera dans les Yvelines
des entrepreneurs des associations et
des habitants se sont rencontrés le but
échanger sur les projets à venir dans le
département plusieurs actions et
initiatives départementales ont été
présentés dont la mise en service de la
centrale thermique dans la copropriété
de Parly 2 à l'automne 2025 alors on le
rappelle la géothermie consiste à
récupérer la chaleur des nappes
phréatiques et à la convertir en énergie
puis de 7500 logements sont concernés et
d'autres établissements également
notamment l'hôpital Mignot André Mignot
l'Hôtel de Ville et la piscine ce qui en
fait le plus grand projet de géothermie
d'Europe on écoute pierre Bédié le
président du département des Yvelines au
micro de Gabriel Gonthier d'abord ça va
permettre aux copropriétaires d'avoir
une économie substantielle puisque le
prix du gaz qu'il payait et le prix du
gaz qu'il paie ont été multipliés par 10
donc vous imaginez la facture absolument
hallucinante qui vont
subir c'est ensuite et pour l'avenir
surtout un projet écologique puisque le
gaz a des émissions d'effet de serre
alors que la géothermie ce qui consiste
à les chercher de l'eau chaude et à
utiliser cette différence entre le chaud
et le froid pour produire
de la chaleur
donc
quelque chose de totalement écologique
Richard Delepierre le coup président du
conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital
André Mignot était lui aussi à présent
une semaine après la cyberattaque à
l'hôpital André Mignot il en a profité
pour faire un point sur la situation on
l'écoute
l'hôpital tourne au ralenti mais plutôt
pas mal on est globalement autour de 70
à 80% des capacités qui contenu de
l'intensité de l'attaque tout à fait
remarquable on travaille en mode papier
crayon mais on a trouvé des équipes
plutôt très réactives qui ont envie de
retourner le plus vite possible à la
normale la question c'est de ne pas
vouloir y retourner trop vite donc et de
et de s'inscrire dans ce qui est plutôt
une course de fond qu'un sprint et puis
la vie de Guyancourt vient de recevoir
une récompense oui et c'est très
compense c'est la victoire d'or du
paysage ce prix remis par valeur
l'interpré l'interprofessionnel de
l'horticulture de la fleuristerie et du
paysage récompense les aménagements
paysagers remarquables la ville de
Guyancourt a donc été primée pour le
réaménagement du my des saules qui a
fait peau neuve en 2019 deux ans après
deux ans de travaux les anciens saules
malades datant des années 70 ont
également été remplacés on écoute la
réaction du maire de Guyancourt François
Morton au micro de Grégory canalet on
est très fier de recevoir cette
récompense parce que quand on a décidé
effectivement cette réhabilitation du
mal des saules ça a pas été sans
difficulté parce que on savait qu'on
s'attaquait à un monument de la ville de
Guyancourt et de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de ce
magnifique maille mais qui était dans un
état un petit peu compliqué avec
notamment la maladie des saules puisque
ces arbres étaient très malades et que
certains de nos concitoyens
effectivement voyez cette réhabilitation
avec un peu d'inquiétude et alors de
nombreuses années après donc maintenant
lorsqu'on reçoit effectivement cette
récompense on est très fier et ça nous
conforte dans l'idée qu'on a bien fait
merci Régine pour ces informations du
jour et si vous aussi près de chez vous
vous êtes témoin d'une information d'un
fait qui vous fait réagir la neige par
exemple qui tombera à cette nuit ou
demain n'hésitez pas à le partager et à
le dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag hashtag 78 news
on va maintenant parler d'un événement
qui s'est déroulé ce samedi 10 décembre
à Voisins-le-Bretonneux la cérémonie
d'intronisation du nouveau conseil
municipal des jeunes s'est déroulés
week-end dernier pour nous en parler et
nous recevons sur ce plateau à la roue
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure le
conseil municipal rapporteur au CMJ
ainsi que deux membres du CMJ yenaël et
Emma bonsoir alors comment s'est
déroulée cette cérémonie d'intronisation
par nous remettre notre écharpe avec la
présence de la député de la
circonscription
une conseillère régionale donc c'était
assez émouvant quand même de recevoir de
la part d'une députée une écharpe
tricolore
puis après on a fait une activité pour
solidariser l'équipe parce qu'on se
connaît pas on se connaissait pas très
bien encore du coup on a fait une
activité pour mieux se connaître
d'intronisation alors surtout la
longévité de ce conseil municipal à des
jeunes à Voisins Bretonneux depuis 1997
comme je soulignais c'est l'un des plus
vieux il fait du top 10 des conseils
municipaux des jeunes en France donc
toute la France de toute la France donc
la longévité c'est à dire 25 ans sans
interruption et puis cette cérémonie est
importante aussi puisque c'est ces
jeunes vont aussi participer à des
cérémonies protocolaires concernant et
bien les le monde du combattant ce qu'on
appelait les anciens combattants et puis
on va aller voir aussi sur d'autres
événements de la ville où ils sont
entièrement partis parties prenantes
concrètement ça sert à quoi un conseil
municipal des jeunes ah conseil
municipal des gens et bien c'est
pérennisé et bien la
l'action en parallèle de ce qui peut se
faire sur sur une ville et eux forcément
ils ont aussi leurs idées le Conseil
Municipal des Jeunes permet aussi dans
dans leur projet d'améliorer tout ce qui
est autour de la jeunesse par exemple
ils ont s'ils ont décidé de faire un mur
avec au lieu d'aller taguer partout dans
la ville ben le conseil municipal des
jeunes il y a quelques quelques années à
dédier un mur spécialement au tag et
puis Lionel Emma peuvent aussi décrire
leurs actions par exemple la World dead
clean up
c'est un événement mondial et bien le
CMG de ramassage de déchets des déchets
et bien le conseil municipal des jeunes
eux a décidé de le renouveler tous les
tous les trimestres et montrer aussi aux
adultes et bien l'exemple et ben
pourquoi vous vouliez faire partie de ce
conseil municipal des jeunes faut avoir
des responsabilités un peu et faire des
actions qui pourraient être favorables
aux jeunes qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
par exemple c'est votre deuxième mandat
si je me trompe pas on a fait des
ramassages de déchets des des actions
personnelles aussi un peu comme on a eu
l'occasion d'aller à l'Assemblée
nationale l'année dernière et ça prend
beaucoup de temps ou pas
on peut aller en politique peut-être
plus tard ce sont investi dans la vie
locale alors c'est tout le souhait c'est
ce qui s'est passé durant cette
cérémonie protocolaire donc les élus ont
effectué leurs vœux de dire à quand le
maire de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
issu du CMJ même si Alexandra ah même si
Alexandra Rossetti
merde de Voisins-le-Bretonneux elle
forcément elle était très elle est
encore très attachée à ce CMJ donc et
pourquoi pas oui je vois toute façon le
yenael est très pertinent dans toutes
ces questions concernant la politique et
comme il dit la démocratie donc et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas yenaël parce
que lui il est intéressé il a vu
la députée est très intéressée pour être
pour être en politique et pourquoi pas
mère de Voisins-le-Bretonneux à moins
que Emma aussi souhaité être mère de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux pourquoi pas en
tout cas c'est tout le souhait qu'on
leur souhaite dernière question juste
votre première action peut-être dans les
prochains jours est-ce que vous avez
déjà en tête une action
d'abord il faut se regrouper proposer
nos actions avant de les réaliser on
vote ce qu'on fait et en fait on a fait
un un bulletin où on a mis toutes nos
idées parce que on a été élu et c'est on
se tient à ce qu'on a écrit dans
notre profession de foi merci à tous les
trois d'être venu sur ce plateau on
suivra avec attention à les réalisations
du conseil municipal des jeunes de
Voisins le bretonneux je vous propose
maintenant de découvrir une histoire
l'histoire d'une yvelinoise en 2021
Séverine Vergonzeane quitte son travail
dans l'événementiel pour se lancer dans
une aventure qui a du sens elle crée son
entreprise prend ton cabas Simone un
camion itinérant les Yvelines son
portrait par Gabriel Gonthier les
journées commencent tôt pour Virginie
verconzen le matin c'est souvent avant
le lever du soleil qu'elle récupère son
camion et sa marchandise dans son
entreprise
donc là c'est mon local commercial c'est
là où je vais stocker en fait une partie
de ma marchandise en sachant qu'elle va
être dispatchée entre eux le camion et
puis là à peine arrivé nous repartons il
faut maintenant récupérer le reste des
produits direction le
Tremblay-sur-Mauldre à 8 km pour
récupérer fruits et légumes de saison
je me sers en légumes après je vais les
peser et puis bah derrière je pars avec
cette marchandise là pour les au moins
les deux prochains jours la chef
d'entreprise a fait le choix de
privilégier le circuit court et la
production locale au maximum et ce en
total transparence avec ses clients j'ai
cette double offre qui reste souvent
français après des fois forcément la
banane l'orange elle vient de loin une
fois la marchandise récupérée et une
dizaine d'aller-retours réalisé pour
charger le camion il est temps de se
rendre sur le lieu de la vente on va du
coup dans une maison de seniors à
château fort il faut savoir que cette
maison de seniors ils ont vraiment pas
grand chose à côté s'adapter à la
demande et l'une des missions de
l'entreprise nous reprenons donc la
route pour château fort à 26 km j'ai un
velouté de tomates
ça ça vous va moi sur OK il vous fallait
des fruits faire un métier qui a du sens
être plus proche des gens c'est pour ces
raisons qu'après 17 ans passés dans
l'événementiel Séverine vergonzen a tout
quitté pour créer son entreprise
voilà tu sais que tu leur apportes
vraiment parce que eux pour le coup il y
a pas de commerce sur le sur le site de
château fort que c'est un moment de
convivialité donc là ça a du sens ça on
est bien ce que vous avez un petit sac
une page économie le dernier numéro du
skyco magazine d'actualité économique du
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
revient très largement sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire l'association envie
actrice dans ce domaine emploi des
personnes en insertion professionnelle
pour reconditionner des produits à
d'électroménager parmi les
collaborateurs Philippe Lanners 63 ans
il travaille pour envie depuis plus de 4
ans Nicolas dandry est allé le
rencontrer et il travaille depuis 5 ans
et demi dans le réseau en vie sur le
site de trap nous sommes avec Philippe
bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes actuellement en train de
réparer ce four qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc je reçois une fiche
donc notifiant donc le problème de la de
la pâte donc c'est à moi chercher à
trouver la panne de cet appareil de ce
front et donc ça c'est quelque chose que
vous faites au quotidien c'est ça voilà
c'est ça
c'est-à-dire qu'on reçoit
d'artistes si vous voulez des
appareils qui sont jetés à la poubelle
d'accord qu'on répare et qu'on nettoie
complètement donc on refait à neuf et
vous êtes spécialisé sur un type
d'appareil en particulier parce qu'on a
vu il y a des machines à laver il y a
des lave-vaisselle tout ce qui est
cuisson donc au four cuisinière plaque
induction et voilà alors pourquoi
votre API à 5 ans et demi j'ai je
travaillais à Lille où j'ai eu en
buremets à Lille et donc je me suis un
peu baladé comme ça sans
en faisant un peu en allant un peu
partout en France et comme j'ai une sœur
qui est ici à Montigny donc c'est plutôt
ma famille qui m'a demandé de
restabiliser baouillé que à l'époque
j'avais 57 ans donc je me posais des
questions à savoir
quel sens vous donnez à votre activité
professionnelle pourquoi vous vous êtes
motivé à vous lever chaque matin
tout d'abord je
j'aime ce travail et c'est vrai que
j'aide beaucoup ici de par mon
expérience donc c'est le fait à des
jeunes il y a beaucoup il y a pas mal de
jeunes qui sont là et je leur apprends
avec mon âge maintenant j'ai 63 ans je
veux dire que j'ai tout ça fait plus de
40 ans que je travaille donc j'ai un
certain savoir et le fait de partager ce
savoir ben voilà ça ça me ça me donne
comment dirais-je une
allez c'est tendre la main aussi vous à
votre tour parce que envie vous attendu
la main et vous c'est aujourd'hui vous
tendez la main aux jeunes et aux autres
collaborateurs qui vous entourent au
quotidien c'est ça je leur dois
pratiquement entre guillemets
ma vie puisque à 57 ans vous ai perdu
bah vous vous posez énormément de
questions et puis
que vais-je faire qui suis-je voilà et
donc là ça vous remet sur sur le bon du
travail et en plus vous aider des jeunes
et donc là c'est à votre tour d'aider
de partager surtout que ces gens-là ont
besoin
parce que c'est de l'insertion donc ce
sont des gens peut-être qui n'ont jamais
terminé leurs études et qui des fois
arrivent à 25 ans sans
rien donc bah il faut leur montrer voilà
ce qu'est le travail être là avec moi à
air fixe et puis respecter le et puis
c'est le mec comme pour moi une rampe de
lancement et à 25 ans qui est si vous
n'avez pas de travail
il y a rien qui suit quoi je veux dire
ils sont encore chez leurs parents en
plus merci beaucoup Philippe
opérateur de production sur le site
envie de trap merci on passe maintenant
notre page culture
on va prendre la direction de la cité
royale pour commencer cette page culture
et les lunes des pièces phares des
jardins du château de Versailles le char
d'Apollon est au cœur d'un immense
chantier de restauration l'oeuvre en
plomb et dans un état dégradé 18 mois de
travaux sont prévus la structure a été
retirée le 6 décembre dernier reportage
de Mélanie poquet et de Mathilde de
Franco
des craquelures qui n'existeront bientôt
plus après le bassin de la tonne les
jardins de Versailles connaissent un
nouveau grand chantier le char d'Apollon
a quitté le domaine le 6 décembre
dernier appelons a subi les outrages du
temps et depuis trois siècles qu'il est
là les structures métalliques qui
portent les sculptures à proprement
parler qui sont en plomb ces structures
métalliques ont rouillées se sont
affaissés et toute la sculpture
a commencé à s'affaisser le char a été
restauré en permanence depuis le 18e
siècle mais en surface cette fois il
faudra décaper toutes les couches de
peinture sur le dessus refaire une
charpente métallique et reformez les
sculptures ce sont des difficultés de
restauration absolument exceptionnelles
que j'allais dire depuis 300 ans
personne ne sait faire il a fallu
plusieurs chantiers successifs à
Versailles entre le bassin de la tonne
aujourd'hui la restauration des
sculptures du buffet de Trianon pour
acquérir le savoir-faire permettant la
manutention de ces groupes géants des
difficultés de transport aussi chaque
élément pesant près de 5 tonnes pour une
sculpture monumentale de 30 tonnes une
restauration plus qu'attendue par les
équipes du domaine qui regardent déjà
vers le futur on est donc d'autant plus
fier de pouvoir le faire maintenant que
comme vous le savez nous préparons les
Jeux olympiques de 2024 et que pour les
épreuves d'équitation qui se dérouleront
ici et bien ce char d'Apollon redoré
flamboyant dans toute sa majesté et bien
servira d'arrière-plan à ces JO le char
d'Apollon trônera à nouveau au centre de
la grande perspective du domaine dans 18
mois comme au temps du roi soleil
il a fait le buzz récemment avec son
nouveau titre Coupe du Monde au Qatar
qui totalise plus de 100 000 vues sur
Youtube le rappeur curta vient de sortir
son nouveau projet musical 7k82 la suite
de son ep7k8 sortie il y a deux ans on y
retrouve 10 titres dont Coupe du Monde
au Qatar ou encore Omar Sy avec 800
inédits également kurta parle de son EP
à Grégory canalet on écoute un extrait
c'est des morceaux que sur lesquels j'ai
vraiment beaucoup travaillé et qui sont
ouverts à tous il y a de la pop il y a
du rap il y a des messages il y a de
quoi s'évader c'est vraiment un projet
qui est je l'espère va vous plaire qui
était quitter le cocon j'ai dit comme
une envie de voir autre chose comme un
goût de métamorphose fini le maquillage
sur le coton en faux quitter quitter le
cocon comme le papillon
comme le papillon
tout comme le papillon le papier
papi comme le copine vous pouvez écouter
cette K8 sur toutes les plateformes
musicales le P sur a également
disponible en physique pour
prochainement
on va maintenant parler à sport la
diagonale des Yvelines revient le
premier avril prochain et ce n'est pas
une blague au programme une traversée en
trail du département avec quatre
épreuves un départ à Breuil boire Aubert
aux étendoland à Rochefort-en-Yvelines
et une arrivée unique à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines pour nous parler
de ce rendez-vous nous sommes avec
l'organisateur Alain Pelot c'est avec le
responsable du parcours Bruno Bachelard
bonsoir alors ce sera la quatrième
édition la course est désormais bien
implantée André Yvelines on peut le dire
oui je pense que maintenant c'est une
course qui commence à un petit peu à
être connue on le voit bien avec les
inscriptions qui qui démarre plutôt bien
et puis depuis un mois
on voit bien aussi que les partenaires
nous suivent dans cette démarche que ça
soit le département des Yvelines et nos
partenaires vestimentaires vous aussi
tv78 que vous êtes avec nous depuis le
début donc je tiens le souligner voilà
donc ça prouve que c'est une course qui
s'inscrit dans le paysage
yvelinois et on en est très contents et
très fier vous sentez que l'événement
monte en puissance Bruno tout à fait à
mesure des années tout à fait les gens
en parlent d'autant plus qu'on l'a on
l'a mutualisé avec des challenges sur
d'autres trails qui se passent également
dans notre dans notre région trail
dessert et autres et donc
automatiquement de bouche à oreille ça
fait une licence de plus ça fait une
distance de 100 km quand même donc ce
qui n'est pas rien je pense que on n'a
pas fait le compte mais c'est d'être le
seul 100 km en trail dans les villes de
France dans l'Île-de-France donc bah
voilà on est là et on tient la barre et
à 50 km et puis cette année et on dit km
en boucle donc une belle boucle dans la
foi de Rochefort est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter un petit peu le parcours
alors voilà peut-être pendant le détail
peut-être pas dans le détail chaque
action
on a réussi à relier tous les lieux
emblématiques qui permettent au trailer
toute l'année de s'entraîner et tout ça
en faisant une diagonale donc avec des
points particuliers bon toute la farine
naturellement la vallée de vos couleurs
au départ sur 100 km les yeux des
étendolantes sont bien connus de tout le
monde dans la région on passe par
refargis et puis sur des petits villages
des petits villages comme la céléborne
pas toujours connu sauf des cyclistes
mais là on va y passer en courant et
puis la foire de Rochefort qui est une
magnifique franchement magnifique à voir
avec un petit pincement au coeur sur
lavé parce que bah sur l'arrivée on va
passer dans la zone qui était incendie
l'année dernière donc pendant l'été tout
à fait et j'ai fait la reconnaissance
cet été et
ça fait quelque chose mais on voit que
la nature revient
au niveau du parcours on regarde à peu
près les mêmes éléments qui font la
réussite du travail depuis quelques
années oui oui bah là encore une fois
donc on va partir de boire Aubert on a
quand même des communes cette année on a
traversé 32 communes 32 communes quand
même sur un parcours c'est quand même
assez inédit et ça je pense que ça plaît
énormément au coureur aussi c'est de
c'est un peu l'esprit du travail le
travail la base c'est courir voilà mais
aussi découvrir des endroits un petit
peu qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de de
partager et donc c'est vraiment
là-dessus qu'on s'attarde et Bruno qui
nous a qui a tout l'été à naviguer sur
les parties des Yvelines nous a trouvé
des parcours assez extraordinaires le
parcours je fais toutes les
reconnaissances en vélo parce que
naturellement en courant perd beaucoup
de temps donc donc en VTT et j'ai passé
l'été à faire tous les chemins de droite
et gauche premier repérage sur et puis
ensuite on va sur le terrain tout
simplement on va parler peut-être de ce
100 km vous l'avez dit c'est peut-être
atypique en France c'est peut-être sur
cette distance là que vous démarquez des
autres travail qui sont proposés dans la
région alors oui et qui attire peut-être
des des champions alors on espère en
tout cas quand on a créé cette course on
a été on avait commencé par un 80
puisqu'on voulait on voulait se tester
on savait pas trop où on allait quand
même 100 km à organiser et 80 ça ne
suffisait pas assez bon en fin de compte
le premier l'objectif qu'on voulait
c'était son on voulait d'une manière
mythique faire le 100 km c'était c'était
un projet qu'on avait dans depuis depuis
très longtemps donc on a commencé par un
80 on a vu que ça fonctionnait bien
qu'on était rodé et on a lancé le 100 km
et c'est vrai que je pense que ça ça va
ça ça attire les gens et ça a quand même
une distance un peu mythique quand même
faire 100 km à travers un département et
encore une fois ça nous permet de
découvrir des endroits magnifiques donc
oui
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient à
cœur ce 100 km ouais Bruno et puis en
course en plus cette course c'est au
printemps donc sortie d'hiver un 100 km
en sortie d'hiver les gens vont pouvoir
se tester et partir ensuite sur deux
trails beaucoup plus importants en
montagne notamment où là on peut pas
s'entraîner s'entraîner l'hiver à cause
de la neige mais là c'est vraiment le
parcours idéal pour préparer sa son
début de saison et aller sur du plus
long pour ceux qui font du de l'ultra et
justement j'allais vous poser la
question on sera au mois d'avril
commencera le terrain
humide ou plutôt sec
la petite histoire
l'année dernière on était un petit peu
dans votre configuration météorologique
actuelle c'est à dire que on avait une
période de neige et donc cette troisième
édition avait été faite sous la neige à
une température au départ il faisait
moins 5 ou moins 6 à breuil-bois Robert
donc je pense que beaucoup de mais ça
donnait ça donne un petit peu de piment
un petit peu à cette course c'est pas
une course facile c'est un 100 km il y a
très peu de dénivelé pour les traders
qui font de la montagne mais il faut
courir il faut garder un rythme et
c'est vrai que la météo est un point
essentiel surtout que on sera la sortie
de l'hiver et le terrain sera où
compliquer alors on a eu des détours on
a même fait des détours la dernière
puisque on avait des zones complètement
inondées bon voilà c'est c'est un vrai
travail quoi c'est c'est un vrai trail
c'est pas très urbain c'est un vrai
travail de de de
rurale et comme les trailers aiment
normalement voilà il y a déjà une
histoire on le comprend sur ce trail
est-ce qu'on peut toujours participer à
ce qu'il reste des places et est-ce que
tout le monde peut s'inscrire alors où
il faut avoir un petit niveau quand même
alors sur le alors nous on a on a créé
en plus parce qu'on aime bien innover on
a créé un petit challenge à l'intérieur
du de ce challenge de 100 km c'est à
dire que on va créer on a créé un défi
de faire le moins de 10 heures on va
récompenser ceux qui feront moins de 10
heures sur le 100 km pour la petite
histoire l'année dernière sur le 100 km
il y en avait que 4 donc on verra
combien on lance ce challenge je pense
que ça va plaire sinon tout le monde
peut y participer sur le 100 km et le 50
km il faut faut vraiment avoir un
entraînement adapté c'est clair sur le
vin et le les Élodie je pense que c'est
adapté sur une découverte un petit peu à
tout le monde et en plus inscrire sur le
site qui apparaît à l'écran
78.fr vous attendez combien de personnes
au total Bruno vous savez je pense que
si on sera satisfait à 700 personnes et
on sera on sera sans content s'il y a
plus
la dernière on a vu des sourires et ça
c'était très important pour nous des
gens qui avaient du plaisir à le faire
et voilà on est tous là les bénévoles
nous suivent on a des bénévoles qui
viennent tous les ans et qui nous
suivent ça c'est super bien très
rapidement j'ai vu que vous aviez des
des t-shirts pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
les montrer rapidement bien sûr alors
pourquoi parce que déjà pour les montrer
mais aussi pour vous les offrir parce
que vous avez une équipe donc je sais
pas à qui je suis bien voilà pour qu'on
participe en fait là je vous ai amené
des t-shirts diagonales des y et puis si
vous voulez monter une équipe TV 78 vous
êtes les bienvenus
qui est très intéressé actuellement en
régie on me le dit dans l'oreillette
donc voilà vous avez combien deux trois
t-shirts pour le droit de faire une
équipe à mon avis et alors je vous
présente les t-shirts phases pas prévoir
le bonnet au mois d'avril comme vous
l'avez dit l'année dernière c'était un
peu compliqué ça passe bon l'avantage
l'année dernière c'est qu'on avait fait
un plat à l'arrivée qui était
tartiflette et je pense qu'on avait eu
le né creux mais bah voilà vous avez pas
encore le plat pour cette année
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau la diagonale des Yvelines et
programmer le premier avril prochain 4
épreuves sont au programme et
traverseront les Yvelines si vous voulez
vous inscrire les inscriptions sont
ouvertes on va maintenant parler cuisine
avec notre rubrique l'astuce du chef
comme chaque mardi un chef des Yvelines
vous propose une recette à réaliser chez
vous aujourd'hui le chef Jean-Baptiste
Lavergne de la table du 11 situé à
Versailles vous propose une recette à
base d'huîtres Céline Charles et
Mathilde de Franco l'ont rencontré
bonjour je suis Jean-Baptiste Laverne
morzani et je vous souhaite la bienvenue
au restaurant La Table du 11 on a
également le Bistrot du 11 et la cave du
11h et ce matin on va réaliser un plat
tout autour de l'huître Gilardeau
gribiche et une sauce balsamique blanc
on va débuter sur l'huître Gillardeau
donc là on est sur la numéro 1 donc
c'est ce qui se fait le plus gros chez
eux c'est le plus gros calibre
pas évidente avec ce producteur là parce
que sur les gros calibre on n'a pas le
côté un petit peu laiteux qui peut être
gênant certaines fois ensuite on va
mettre un vinaigre de sapin donc bio qui
vient des Vosges on va venir tourner
autour de notre filtre
ensuite on va continuer avec la sauce
gribiche
ensuite sauce balsamique blanc
ensuite huile de persil on va venir
remplir la partie blanche de l'assiette
qui nous reste en visuel
ensuite on va mettre graines de moutarde
réhydratée fraîche
pour mettre la dernière touche végétale
on va utiliser le shiso donc on va
mettre une demi-feuille de chez au frais
et on va terminer avec une feuille de
shiso qu'on vient travailler en tempora
pour avoir un côté un peu croustillant
sur le plat
et voici l'huître Gilardeau avec sauce
gribiche et sauce balsamique blanc donc
là l'idée pour avoir la sauce gribiche
qui est naturellement une sauce un petit
peu gourmande qui se mange avec la tête
de veau avec des morceaux là on vient
faire une sauce très lisse donc l'idée
c'est que vous mettiez tous vos
ingrédients de la sauce de biche dans un
mixeur vous mixez tout ensemble et
ensuite vous la passez au chinois et
vous aurez une sauce très lisse en tout
cas je vous souhaite bon appétit
ça donne très envie de réaliser à cette
recette à la maison et pourquoi pas pour
Noël avant de vous laisser on termine
par la météo de demain elle va
particulièrement vous intéresser j'en
suis sûr on en a parlé dans cette
émission la neige fera son grand retour
dans les Yvelines il devrait neiger
entre deux à 5 cm 7 nuits de la neige
qui pourrait tomber aussi dans la
matinée et les températures seront
négatives entre -1 et -2° sur tout le
département ce qui va permettre à la
neige de tenir dans l'après-midi il
faudra encore garder son bonnet ses
gants le thermomètre affichera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 0° à Versailles ou
dans et Rambouillet la neige continuera
à tomber légèrement avec des pluies
verglaçantes dans l'après-midi dans le
sud des Yvelines et un nouvel épisode
neigeux devrait arriver dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi ce mercredi 14 décembre
nous fêterons les Odile c'est la fin du
7 8 merci à vous de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez retrouver notre émission sur le
site internet
tv78.com le 7 8 revient demain pour une
nouvelle édition et peut-être sous la
neige belle soirée sur TV